اقنعه النوم او ضمانات العينين التي نضعها
لحجم الضوء وتحسين نوعيه النوم قد تسبب
مشاكل صحيه كبيره بالفعل اخصائيه بصريات
بريطانيه قالت عبر صحيفه ان قناع النوم
يمكن ان يلتقط البكتيريا والاوساخ
والماكياج والعرق ايضا حذرت الطبيبه ان
عدم غسل هذه الاقنعه واستبدالها كل فتره
يمكن ان يسبب التهابات في العينين
والاعراض الاوليه هي احمرار وافرازات عند
الاستيقاظ على العموم هناك نسخ ذكيه من
اقنعه النوم يتجاوز دورها حسب الضوء فقط
ولها مميزات مختلفه من تقديم تقارير ايضا
عن النوم وامكانيه التنبيه وحتى مكافحه
الشخير انا بالنسبه للامنيات الغير
تقليديه بدي هاي
ههه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات